MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good
morning, everyone.
This is Jarek Wilkiewicz,
Google Developer Live.
We have in the studio
Jeremy Walker.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, hello.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: Pretty good.
How are you doing?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I'm doing good.
Trying to wake up
this morning.
It's still a little early.
On the Hangout, we have Jeffrey
Posnick joining us
live from New York City.
How's life in New York, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK: [INAUDIBLE]
three hours late here, so I'm
fully woken up and post-lunch
and ready to go.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All
right, great.
And today JJ Behrens, our
fearless host, decided to take
a step back and enjoy the
view from the couch.
So you guys can't see him, but
he's in the studio in person
with us laughing right now.
OK, so we have an exciting
program for you today.
We'll be talking about a
not so secret but not
released set of APIs.
We have discussed them briefly
at Google I/O previously.
So if you were at Google I/O,
you might have participated in
a code lab that Jeff and a
couple of API developers have
run over there.
We'll be talking about YouTube
API v3 as well as our new
Analytics API.
As we mentioned in previous
episodes of this show, these
are right now in developer
preview.
So if you would like to use
them, you have to apply using
the developer console.
And some of you might actually
get to use them.
We are still a little selective
about the use cases
that we want to test out before
we launch the APIs, but
hopefully, it's not going
to be that much longer.
I know Jeremy is eagerly
awaiting API v3 because I
think he thinks v2
is kind of old.
Is it?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
Yeah, I've started playing
around with v3, and I do like
it a bit more.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
And then I think what we
should do now is just
transition over to Jeff, who
is going to walk us through
the intricacies of v3, using
client APIs, and getting the
most out of the Analytics API.
So over to you, Jeff.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
Thanks, guys.
Yeah, so it'll be interesting to
see how this goes, because
I think we could probably spend
a couple hours talking
about these new APIs.
And I don't know if anybody
really wants to hear me talk
for a few hours.
So I'm going to try to touch on
some of the highlights and
start by talking a bit about
the background of these new
APIs and what makes them so
different than what we've
offered before.
So first of all, in the case
of YouTube Analytics, we
haven't really offered the
same sort of API before.
We've added YouTube Insights
API, which did provide ways of
getting data related to your
YouTube account performance,
but that was a very limited API
in that we only exported a
zip file that contains a bunch
of comma-separated values
documents within it.
It's very hard to parse that
information and to use it in a
meaningful way.
So what we're going to be
rolling out when we release
the YouTube Analytics API is a
real full-featured, RESTful
JSON API for retrieving all
sorts of different types of
YouTube reports.
It's going to be similar in some
senses to the existing
Google Analytics API.
Some of the report definitions
look very similar.
So if you've used that before,
or if you've written code
that's gone against it, some of
that will also apply to the
Analytics API.
On the other hand, we have
the v3 of the Data API.
And as the name implies, we've
also had a v1 and a v2, so
this isn't something brand new
in terms of the type of things
that if offers.
But we are going to be very
happy to roll out some new
features that are only going
to be part of the V3 API.
But the real way to think
about it is that this is
rewriting APIs on a more
solid foundation.
These APIs are all going to be
built on top of Google's new
common API infrastructure.
You know, our previous
infrastructure is referred to
pretty much as Google
Data, or G Data.
And those APIs that were written
against that were all
RESTful, but they used Atom
XML as their native
interchange format.
And there were a certain set
of client libraries that
weren't particularly well
maintained that went against
those older APIs.
But because we're building on
top of this new beautiful
infrastructure, we're going to
be able to take advantage of
everything else that--
all the effort that Google is
putting into their APIs across
all platforms.
So if you've used Google+'s
APIs before, if you used
things like Google Latitudes, if
you've used the new Google
Drive APIs, then you've already
built on top of this
infrastructure, and you are
already will be familiar with
a lot of things when you
get started with
the new YouTube APIs.
And as I mentioned before, these
are all RESTful APIs.
So if you are familiar with
making URL requests and
getting back data, if you get
that, this all should be very
similar to what you've done
in the past, except JSON--
JavaScript Object Notation--
is the native format.
So you don't have to worry
about parsing XML.
As far as I know, we're not even
going to be offering any
sort of XML-based options.
It really is JSON all the way.
And I think a lot of
people are going to
be happy about that.
We have a lot of folks who've
previously used Version 2 of
the Data API and had to manually
specify that they
wanted to get JSON back, but
it wasn't the default.
And I think that this was the
right choice moving forward in
terms of making it easier
for folks to
interact with the APIs.
So I'm going to start this
screen-sharing session now and
start showing off a few things
related to new API
infrastructure.
And hopefully, this will be
visible for everybody out
there who's watching
after the fact.
But if it's not, we're going
to share the links to all
these things I'm covering--
well, most of the public
things I'm covering--
after the fact.
And we'll probably post that on
our YouTube for Developers
Google+ page.
So the first thing I wanted to
point out is we have this
really nice web page--
developers.google.com--
and this is the home for all
our APIs now, including
YouTube APIs.
And one of the things on there
is a list of all the client
libraries that we support
with the new Google APIs
infrastructure.
So you'll see it's a
pretty nice list.
There are nine officially
supported client libraries for
various languages.
And I was actually
poking around.
I saw that somebody is doing I
guess an unofficial version of
these client libraries for
PEARL, which maybe isn't as
relevant today as it
was 10 years ago.
But it's still kind of cool that
there are some folks--
even if it's not an official
client library, there are some
folks who are taking it upon
themselves to try to implement
something that works
against our APIs.
But many of the major languages
that everybody out
there is probably programming
against are covered here.
I know that folks who are, for
instance, Python programmers--
this just came up a little bit
earlier today in a Google
group, people saying, hey, why
isn't there Python client
library support for Version
2 of the API?
Python folks have been kind of
left out in the dust for a
while, unfortunately, and I'm
happy to say that we're going
to have full-featured rich
support for Python developers
in Version 3 of the API.
One of the things that's
actually nice about the way
the client libraries are set up,
not just for the YouTube
API, but for anything built
on top of the Google APIs
infrastructure, is that many of
them dynamically generates
the classes that are necessary
to interact with the relevant
APIs at run time rather than
having to pre-compile the
classes ahead of time, and you
have to make sure that your
library is always up to date and
that we didn't release new
definitions of what the API will
look like two weeks ago,
and you just never updated your
local copy of the client
library to match that.
The ones that I know for sure
that are doing this at run
time are JavaScript,
Python, and Ruby.
And the way that works is that
they will contact our servers.
We have this central definition
document for--
I guess we're calling
it a discovery
document for the API.
That just details all the
methods and data types that
the API supports.
So when you run your code, the
first thing it does is it'll
download that document.
It'll build up all the client
descriptions that are necessary.
And you never have to worry
about your code being out of
date or not matching the
API definition again.
So that's going to be a real
benefit for folks who have
struggled in the past with
client libraries that have
been out of date.
And like I said, that's
not the case for
every single language.
I think for Java, for
instance, we need to
pre-generate some of
those classes.
But I think you'll see that
we're a lot better about
getting fresh copies of those
class definitions pushed out
when v3 is released.
One other thing to note about
this new client library,
especially for the Java version,
is that is fully
compatible with Android.
And this has been a bit of a
pain point for developers who
have in the past tried to use
Version 2 of the Data API on
the Android platform.
The existing G Data client
library wasn't really a good
fit for an Android
environment.
I think there might have been
some folks who've found ways
to get the G Data client
library to work.
But really, you have to end up
just writing your own, making
your own HTTP calls and parsing
adjacent data yourself
if you wanted to use a Version
2 of the API on Android.
So once Version 3 is available
and once the Analytics API--
everything I say here also
applies to Analytics API.
Once those are available, you'll
be able to use the
official client library for
Java, and there's going to be
plenty of examples out there
of how you could do that on
the Android environments.
So that's a little bit about
the infrastructure.
And one of the things that I
feel bad about is that folks
can't really play around with
the APIs themselves quite yet.
So as Jareck mentioned at the
top, we're still in kind of a
closed beta, or in some cases
alpha release of these APIs.
So I'm going to show you the
steps that you will be able to
go through soon--
for some definition of soon--
to get started building
against the APIs.
And file this video away.
You can go back and
look at it later.
There's actually some other good
video resources out there
that explain these steps from
the context of other APIs.
Not necessarily YouTube API, but
a lot of these steps are
common regardless of what
API you're using.
So I'll just walk you through
that a little bit here.
So what I'm at right now is what
we're calling our Google
APIs Console.
You can get through
it by going to
code.google.com/apis/console.
And I have an existing project
over here, and I'm going to
walk you through the steps
of creating a new one.
So whenever you're building
against a new Google APIs
platform, you need to first
to register a project.
And this concept is different
for folks who might be--
shoot, try a new one.
It's different for folks who
might be used to just, for
instance, registering
a developer key.
If you are a Version 2
developer, you probably are
familiar with the process of
registering YouTube API
developer keys.
This API console replaces
the need to do that.
And it's nice because it applies
to all Google APIs, as
you're not just registering a
YouTube API developer key.
You're registering one project
identity that's common
throughout all the APIs
you're using.
So if you're using the YouTube
API, and the YouTube Analytics
API, and maybe the Google
Analytics API, and maybe the
Google Drive API all within the
same project, you have one
central place to manage
all the things
specific to that project.
And that's the API Console.
Let's say GGL Test Project.
Just create that.
So the first step is creating
a new project if you don't
already have one.
And you're then taken to this
list of different APIs that
you could enable.
So before you could use any API,
you just have to click on
Enable over here.
And we're over here going to
see just a Request Access.
That's the link that folks are
going to see if they are not
yet permissioned.
And I'm afraid most folks are
going to be in that state
right now because I'm the one
who controls the permission
things to some extent.
I was able to turn on YouTube
Analytics API and YouTube Data
API for my specific project.
So sorry about that, but again,
folks are not always
going to be in that boat.
But it is something that we
are turning on for select
users right now.
Once it's fully available,
you'll be able to just flip
the switch and enable that
for your project.
And once you have the project
set up, you can
do a number of things.
The relevant stuff that you want
to think about is under
the API Access tab.
And this is where you get some
of the identifiers that you're
going to need to use if you
want to talk to either the
YouTube API or really any of the
APIs that you've enabled
for your project.
So we have a concept of
both authenticated and
unauthenticated requests against
the YouTube API.
Unauthenticated requests are
just requests made without the
credentials of any given user.
There are many types of requests
that you can make
unauthenticated, such as
search requests-- for
instance, searching for videos
or getting the contents of a
given playlist things
like that.
For those types of calls, you
can look in the Simple API
Access section on this web page,
and you can get your API
key directly from there.
So that is just a piece
of identification.
That doesn't actually
authenticate you or have any
authorization, but it just
associates your API calls with
this given API Console
project.
So it's slightly different for
folks who are used to being
able to make completely
anonymous calls against v2,
where you didn't even have to
specify a developer key.
But it's not really that much
of a burden to take that
particular key and use that
in your application.
So that's where you get the
unauthenticated API key from.
But all the interesting stuff
nowadays happens with OAuth 2
and authenticator requests.
So this is also where you set up
your OAuth 2 app for this.
For folks who are not familiar
with OAuth 2 and maybe not
familiar with the rather
interesting legacy that we
have of various older and
currently deprecated forms of
authentication authorization
that the YouTube API supported
at one time, OAuth 2 is what
we're recommending everybody
use nowadays.
Even with our older APIs.
But it's the only form of
authorization that's supported
with both the v3 API,
Data API, and the
YouTube analytics API.
Everybody needs to
use OAuth 2.
There's no more client login.
There's no more Auth sub.
And even OAuth 1 isn't something
that we support.
So I will post some links to
some great getting started
resources with regards to OAuth
2 on our YouTube for
Developers G+ page because it's
a rather large topic.
I've given talks about it in
the past where I've spent
about 40 minutes going
over everything.
There's even a book about now
written by one of our
colleagues at Google Developer
Relations.
So there's lots of ways to get
started about that, but the
important thing is that when
you're setting up your OAuth 2
access, you need to generate
things like a client ID, and
in some cases, a
client secret.
You can get that information
from here.
And I'm going to hand over
regenerating all these key
values as soon as we're done
since they're not particularly
secret anymore now that they're
being broadcast out
there, which is actually nice.
So you can go and reset these
things rather than having to
be stuck with your information
being public.
So I'll show you a little bit
later where these values end
up getting plugged in when
you're writing real code that
talks to the new APIs.
But just keep in the
back of your head--
the API Access tab and the API
Console is where you go to
generate that information.
I can just show you right now
what that interface looks like
where you generate
a new client ID.
You choose whether your
application is a web
application, an installed
application, or a service
account, which is actually a
fairly new concept that we
just recently rolled out.
For most YouTube API developers,
I think it's going
to be either a web application,
which is pretty
much anything that's run in a
web browser, really, or an
installed application, which
could be things that are
either command line scripts,
or if you're writing code
that's being run on a specific
type of console or device that
doesn't have a web browser,
that would be another case
where you would use
the installed
application for that.
So that's just how
you create that.
So I showed you how you
can create a project.
It's a little bit of a tease
because you can't actually use
those APIs yet in your
own project.
But where we can play around
with those APIs is on this
web-based interface to
old Google APIs.
So we call it the
APIs Explorer.
And you get there by going
to developers.googl
e.com/apis-explorer.
And I think that's all you
need to go to, yeah.
And you'll get to see a full
list of APIs that we have.
And for our purposes, we could
play around with either the
YouTube Analytics API
or the YouTube API
directly in a browser.
So again, this won't let you
write your own code that will
interact with the APIs.
But it will let you make sample
calls against the APIs
and get the results back
in a web browser.
And you can do this yourself.
You don't have to be
permissioned ahead of time.
One of the nice things is that
it will also take care of
doing OAuth 2 for us.
So flipping the switch
over here--
authorize request
using OAuth 2.
I'm going to just click
that, and I'm
going to click Authorize.
And now I've gone through the
OAuth 2 flow, basically.
Because I was already logged
in to my Google account, I
didn't have to type in my
username and password again.
So it was just the authorization
stuff.
But now I've authorized the
Google APIs Explorer to make
requests on my behalf.
And let's try some here.
So first of all, you could
do some universal search.
This is truly universal
search.
If you were previously doing
searches against the Version 2
API, you might know
that you only got
back videos by default.
There were ways of doing channel
searches and playlist
searches, but they would
be at different points.
So you couldn't really just do
one search that would return
the most relevant videos and
channels and play lists.
In Version 3, you can.
So let's try it out
to start with.
So let's put in YouTube API.
That'll be our search string.
There's a couple of other fields
that you could fill out
if you want to, but we'll just
leave them as default for now.
And let's click Execute.
And we get an error.
So this is one of the reasons
why we don't have things
opened up to everybody
right yet.
There are people doing active
development pretty much as we
speak on the API.
And I had heard there was an
issue this morning with doing
unauthorized requests for
searches, just due to some
random bug.
And I thought that an authorized
request would work,
but as it turns out,
it doesn't.
So play around with this
maybe tomorrow or
in a couple of days.
That's specific to this
search list, though.
But there are a few other things
that should work, such
as doing a channels list.
So I'm in this case going
to try to retrieve this.
This is the typical one that you
make to get a list of your
YouTube channel, basically.
So you can see this is doing
a request against
googleapis.com/y
outube/v3alpha/channels.
I'm saying that this is mine.
And here's a key, or API key.
The Google APIs Explorer
automatically fills
in the key for you.
So you don't have to register
your own key, as we talked
about before.
So don't worry about
that part.
So you'll see the response.
This is a very basic response.
It shows me that I have this
identifier for my channel.
And pretty much just saying
this is the ID.
It happens to be a channel.
And that's something that is due
to the fact that I've only
specified ID as the part that
I want when I get a response
back from the API.
So this is actually a very
important concept that's
probably going to take
developers some time to get
used to when they start
working with v3 API.
If you've done any development
against the v2 API, you know
that by default we give
you everything.
If you request a video entry,
for instance or if you request
your YouTube channel entry,
you'll get every piece of
metadata that is within
the API by default.
And it is possible to filter
out some of that metadata.
And a lot of people do that
because they don't need to get
a couple of kilobytes maybe or
several hundred bytes worth of
data back when all they
care about is a
channel ID, for instance.
So in order to save
speed, save--
sorry--
transmission time, and just
optimize things, they'll say--
[SNEEZE]
JEFFREY POSNICK: Bless you.
They'll say, hey, I'll use the
filter parameter and say that
I only want the ID back.
So that was how things
are done in v2.
We've kind of rethought things
in v3, and we've said, OK,
well, instead of people having
to specifically tell us what
they don't want and by default
giving them everything, how
about we make people
specifically say that they do
want certain parts
of the response.
And if they don't ask for it,
we don't give it to them.
So this does mean that there's
a little bit of work that
needs to be done on your
part in order--
no pun intended--
in order to determine
which parts you want
to get back in response.
But once you do that, you'll
realize that hey, you're
getting back a lot more
optimized responses
than you used to.
So if I put ID, which is a very
basic part, I will only
get back this identifier over
here for my channel.
I could also put in the
content details.
That's another relevant one.
And these are all in our
documentation right now.
So I'm trying to remember a few
relevant ones, but I can
actually just pop over to the
dots and take a look.
But it's just adding in that
content details, though.
That created an extra
subsection
within the JSON response.
It has all the content
details.
And in this case, it has the
identifier of my uploads list,
and the fact that this is
a public list of videos.
So let me just pull up
our docs real quick.
See the big Experimental
next to Version 3.
And I'm going to be doing
a channels list.
So I'm going to go to Reference,
Channels, List.
And I'm going to
look over here.
It says Parts.
And you can see a definition
of types of
supported values for parts.
So we have ID, Content
Details, Snippet, and
Statistics.
So let me actually include all
that and just show you the
full response I could
get back.
And just comma separate
a string.
Click Execute.
So you see a bunch more data.
And this should be more familiar
for folks who have
done v2 type responses, and
they're used to getting back
things like the number of views
for all the videos in
your channel.
The total number of public
videos, your subscribers, a
thumbnail for my account
and its title
and things like that.
One of the interesting things
is the part that
was entitled Snippet.
Most of our API endpoints do
support the snippet part.
And this is kind of a shorthand
that we've come up
with to say that you want to
get back the most relevant
information in a response that
would be useful when
displaying that response
visually somewhere.
So the type of things that you
need when displaying something
visually are usually a
title, description,
some sort of thumbnail.
That's usually enough in order
to give you a very basic
visual representation
of something.
So that's the type of things
you get back in Snippet.
You get back the title.
You get back a thumbnail.
My channel doesn't happen to
have a description so there's
nothing there.
But you'll see the same sort of
thing if we, for instance,
do a video query.
So let's just pick a video
ID real quick.
And I'll just grab one from
our Player API demo page.
That's always a good place
to go to get a video ID.
So we have that ID.
And we're just going to go back
over here to Videos List,
look for an ID.
That, or you put in
Parts, Snippet.
We'll do an Execute, and here
w get back something very
similar to the folks who are
familiar with Version 2.
You have title description.
Tags are useful.
You have this back
in the snippet.
You have video category
in various thumbnails.
I know this is a little bit
specific to folks who have
written code, especially doing
JavaScript parsing of Version
2 responses.
But you'll know that it's very
difficult, for instance, to
figure out what the high-quality
thumbnail is for
when you're parsing
the v2 response.
You kind of have to iterate
through all the items and
check one of the JSON
attributes.
And it's quite annoying.
So one of the nice things that
we've done is we've made it so
you can just do Thumbnails, and
then do a few things that
has the property value high
within that, and then get the
property of the URL.
And it makes things a
little bit easier.
So we've tried to make those
types of little changes
through the API.
So those are a few examples.
And try a little bit
more on your own.
I'm not going to show off the
Analytics API right this
second, meaning I don't
have very useful
information in my accounts.
But you could do the same sort
of requests over here.
It's a little trickier to format
the proper values for
the IDs field, for instance,
which needs to be set to
content to channel equals the
channel identifier string,
which is something distinct
from your username.
You're going to have to spend a
little time looking through
the Docs if you want to
get started on this
completely on your own.
Otherwise, you can wait until
we release some sample code.
That makes it a little
easier for folks to
use these new APIs.
But I just wanted to throw the
fact that people can play
around with Analytics
API now, too.
So one thing that I just want
to go back for a second and
talk about, because it's another
thing that's important
when thinking about the API,
is the fact that--
let me put in Content,
Details, and no.
Edit Picture.
All right.
There we go.
So you'll notice that we have
returned to the uploads this
uu, and then a pretty long
string of characters
identifiers.
This is our way of moving
towards a universal name space
for different types of video
lists and making it possible
to retrieve any type of list of
videos using a single API
method, regardless of whether
it's a list of videos that
somebody has uploaded, or
it's a list of videos
somebody has favorited.
Or it's a list of videos that
belong in a given play list.
Or if it's a list of videos that
a user has Liked in the
past, which is something
new that we're going
to be rolling out.
All those things correspond to
specific list identifiers that
have different prefixes.
So uu is the prefix being
used for the uploads
feed, more or less.
And pl, many people have seen
the pl prefix used on list
identifiers on the website
in the past.
So the same pl identifiers can
now be passed directly into
Methods in the API.
So I just copied that.
I'm going to show you
how that's done.
If you do play list
items list.
I'm going to put
in Snippet ID.
And I'm going to put in the
ID of my group section.
And I'm going to put in the ID
of my uploads list and then
click Execute.
This should work.
And this will show me all
the videos that are
uploaded in my account.
So again, this would have worked
equally well if I had
put in a PL ID over here, if I
had an actual playlist ID.
So we're treating lists of
videos as if they were just
lists of videos, regardless
of what their origin is.
And that should make things
easier from your end in terms
of implementing code.
So just one other thing
I wanted to point out.
So I've showed you a bunch of
demos that are done in the web
interface now.
I've talked about
the API Console.
I did want to show some very
preliminary Python code, in
this case, where we're doing
some of the same things we've
done before via the
web interface.
So in this particular case, I'm
going to show you a Python
example that's used within
Google APIs Python library
that will make an authenticator
request to
Channels List to get the uploads
list identifier, the
same identifier we were just
talking about previously.
And then it will take that
identifier and make a playlist
items list call to get all the
videos in my uploads feed.
So it's pretty much exactly what
we just saw in the web
interface, except some Python
code to do that.
So before I run through the
code, let me show you what it
actually looks like because I
always like doing that first.
So I can run my uploads.py.
And you'll notice that it
immediately will take me to
this page where I can quick
Allow Access, and complete the
OAuth 2 flow.
So this is [INAUDIBLE], and
you'll see the list of all the
videos in my account, including
a bunch of videos
from my site.
So this is possible because we
are using Google APIs Python
client library, and that has a
really good support for OAuth
that's already built into it.
So we don't have to worry about
the details of actually
handling the redirects, for
instance, or even persisting
the credentials after we've
authorized for the first time.
The client library will take
care of all that for us, and
I'll show you how--
excuse me--
from looking at the code.
And one other thing to note is
that the second we run it, I
don't have to go through the
OAuth 2 authorization again.
It'll persist those tokens for
us and it'll reduce them.
So while it might seem a little
bit weird, hey, why do
I have to open up a web browser
when I have a command
line installed application?
Yeah, that's not ideal for
automated processes, but you
only have to do it once.
And as long as you don't
revoke your OAuth 2
credentials, you can reuse
those cached credentials
pretty much indefinitely.
So in that respect, you don't
have to store your username or
password anywhere on the
local file system.
You're storing these opaque
credentials in a file that
only your user has access to.
So it really is a win from a
security perspective, and it's
really, really not that much
harder than doing something
like client login with a
username and password.
I can't talk about all the
details of how the Python
client library handles things.
There's a lot of magic
that's going on.
And Jared Gregorio, who's on our
team and wrote this, did a
wonderful job of that.
And he's made it so that you
have to just put in a couple
lines of code and it'll take
care, of instance, the OAuth 2
flow for you
So this literally is all you
need to do to do OAuth 2 from
within your Python
application.
You have to initialize
this flow object.
And you're saying you're loading
the flow from a client
secrets file.
A client secrets file is a
JSON-formatted file that
contains the client ID, and the
client's secret, and the
redirect scopes, and few other
things that came from the API
Console in a previous call.
So you just store that
somewhere locally.
There's some spec for
how you create that
client secrets file.
I don't want to go into it right
now, but there's spec
for how to do that
link-to from the
Python client library.
And we always said that
we wanted to do the
scope off the YouTube.
And we're saying the next line,
that we want to use this
particular file for storage.
So just hold on one second.
You can hear some pings
in the background--
I'm sorry.
So we're saying that we want
to use this particular file
for storage.
And I'm sorry--
Jareck or Jeremy, interrupt me
if there's something I should
be doing there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think
we are mesmerized
by your code, Jeff.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Pardon?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We are
mesmerized by your code, so
we're in a trance right
now, salivating
over that Python code.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
You know what?
I am always embarrassed showing
off my Python code in
front of JJ, in particular,
because he's
a true Python guru.
So JJ, mercifully, is not
on the camera today.
Otherwise he'd probably be
talking about my indentation,
for instance, which is the
worst thing you could get
reprimanded for if you're
a Python programmer.
In any case, though, we have
the definition of where the
local file is for storing
your credentials.
And we try to reuse the
credentials over here.
So we see if the credentials
are valid.
If they are, we'll reuse them.
If they're not, then we'll
just go through the whole
flow, which opens up the web
browser for us automatically.
It'll actually run local
web server for us.
So the web browser will
end up redirecting to
a local host URL.
And that Python lone server
that's running will listen for
the response.
And once it gets the response,
it'll complete the OAuth 2
flow for us without us really
having intervene at all.
So it's super nifty.
And at that point, we create
this YouTube object.
And over here, we are doing what
I mentioned before, where
it generates the client
bindings on the
fly, more or less.
So what we do is we call the
build method, and we say I'm
using the YouTube service in the
v3 alpha version, and it's
going to go and download the
discovery document for us.
And it's going to build all the
necessary bindings that we
need without us having to have
that precompiled or stored
anywhere ahead of time.
So it's always going
to be fresh.
And at this point, we're doing
a channels list call on that
YouTube object, specifying the
same sort of frameworks we saw
in the web UI.
And we're going to then iterate
over the response.
So we get back a list
of channels.
We iterate over that.
And I only have one channel,
which most
people certainly would.
And it's the content details
upload list ID that we want to
grab over here.
And we're then going to
pass that to this
youtube.playlistitems.list
call.
Very similar, again, to
the web interface.
This playlistid.list_id and the
part is Snippet, and we
can then iterate our
other response.
So again, this is all JSON data
that you get back, and it
gets deserialized into Python
objects that you can then
interact with.
So we're grabbing the
title, and we're
grabbing the video ID.
And I end up printing that
out in a user interface.
We can write that.
So that's a really
simple example.
We're going to release some
examples for doing Analytics
reports in the near future.
We're going to list--
I would show you the Search
example right now, but the
search service isn't currently
working the way it should, so
it wouldn't be a good demo.
And we're going to be trying to
get out as much sample code
as we can as soon as we can,
perhaps even before the public
release of the both v3 and
the Analytics API.
Because we know that sample code
is really what a lot of
developers go on when they're
getting started with any sort
of new API.
So if you don't hear too much
from me in the Google
Developer forums, it's because
I'm head down writing sample
code for everybody.
And I think that's pretty much
what I wanted to show for now.
I've used a nice
chunk of time.
As I mentioned, I probably
could end up using a lot.
more.
So if you ever see me on the
street in New York City, feel
free to corner me
and ask me about
any sort of API questions.
I get that so much, paparazzi
just following me around and
wanting to get early access to
v3 or wanting to know random
things about v2.
So feel free to do so.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Actually, I
think JJ, if he were live, he
would have said that you
actually predict what
questions people are likely to
ask, then you follow them and
answer before they have
a chance to ask them.
Is that right, JJ?
JJ BEHRENS: That's right.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
JJ is nodding his head.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Well, that's
using the Google Prediction
API, which is one of the
APIs we didn't cover.
But yeah, add the Google
Prediction API to your own
code, and you can do the same.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you're
training the algorithm while
people ask you questions?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes,
that's right.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Ah,
this is your secret.
All right.
So we have a few questions.
There were actually questions
on the live stream in the
comments section as well
as in the Moderator.
So let's take a few.
So let's start with
the Moderator.
The top-ranked question is
about obtaining video
thumbnails that look
like a storyboard.
So there's a question whether
our existing Version 2 API
provides that in the
API responses.
And I think the answer is not
this moment, right, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
So we do expose three different
thumbnails from
those videos that are tagged
with, I think,
start, middle, and end.
That is different than what I
think the person is asking
about, which is they've noticed
that the YouTube
player for a lot of videos--
I don't know what percentage
of videos nowadays,
but a lot of them--
lets you move over the scrub
bar with your mouse.
And you see a thumbnail of that
given point in the video.
So that's something new that
we've started doing.
We're not exposing that level of
thumbnail data via the API.
I kind of doubt that
we ever will.
I'm not going to say that for
sure, but I'm not aware of any
plans for us to do anything
more than the beginning,
middle, and end.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Thanks, Jeff.
Again, if this is something that
is important and you guys
feel like we should, then please
file that in our issue
tracker on the public side--
it's linked from
youtube.com/dev--
and we will push on your
behalf to see if
we can make it happen.
But as Jeff mentioned,
right now no plans.
Next question is about
retrieving
multiple parts of a response.
So as Jeff mentioned, there's
a convenient way to obtain,
for example, snippets that will
give you a set of data
elements relevant for display.
Now, what does response
look like if you
actually ask for more?
Can you do that, first, and then
what does it look like?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah,
you definitely can.
So I'll just pull that up
again via screenshare.
That would be the easiest
way to do that.
Let me try to share just
the window this time.
So if you go to the Google
APIs Explorer.
And I guess the most relevant
way to do it is for the
example where we do
the videos list.
So let me just pull
up that video ID.
So prat is just a
comma-separated list of parts.
And if you specify multiple
ones, it'll be the union of
all those parts.
And if I go over here, Reference
and take Videos
List, and then take
a look over here.
Actually, one thing to note is
that instead of just going to
the APIs Explorer, we do have
an embedded version of the
APIs Explorer that is tied to
the specific service that
you're looking at in the Docs.
So right now I'm looking
at Videos List.
And if you go over here, you'll
see pretty much the
same user interface.
It's really just a tiny subset
of it, but it's already on the
user's list method.
So I can just put it over
here equally well.
So let me do that instead.
So let's just get the
list of parts.
Copy that over here.
Whole bunch of different
parts, like for this.
I'm pretty sure--
well, let's actually try to see
if we have spaces in there
whether it likes it.
OK, so it's happy enough
even with spaces.
So this just shows you-- and
here if I take a look at
minimizing some things, which is
a nice thing to do, you'll
see you have this parent
element, parent container
element, whose value is actually
the same as the ID.
So this makes is easy if you're
looking at multiple
video IDs at once, for instance,
you can specify
three or four or whatever video
IDs, you'll know what
part of the response corresponds
to the specific
video you're interested
in just by using
that ID as a key.
So in this case, we're
only looking at one.
But within here you'll see
there's a snippet item.
There's a constant details,
statistics, status, and player.
And those each have their
own subsections with
information within it.
So you can definitely specify as
many as you like, or as few
as you like.
If you only want to know what
the view count is for a given
video, then all you need to do
is put down statistics and
forget all that other
information
that you don't want.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Great.
Thanks, Jeff.
There is one more comment
in the Moderator.
It's in English and in
Mandarin, I suppose.
It's Like.
So my response to that is
thank you very much.
And I'm not really that good
with Mandarin, but I will
answer in Polish.
[SPEAKING POLISH].
But let's transition to a couple
of the questions that I
saw popping up in the live
feed in the comments.
So one question was about
YouTube iOS as far the API is
concerned, is there a
new YouTube iOS API?
And I think, Jeff, you were
talking about the different
client libraries.
So I think the question really
is, what about the iOS?
Is the v3 actually helping
developers in any way?
JEFFREY POSNICK: There
definitely is a client library
for Objective-C that will be
available for use in both
version three of the API and
the YouTube Analytics API.
It will help developers, but
it's actually, interesting for
Objective-C because we didn't
really have quite the same
problem with the Objective-C
client library in v2 as we did
with maybe Java, for instance,
or Python, where either the
bindings were pretty out of date
or there was no really
good support for OAuth 2.
That really hasn't been the case
with Objective-C. We have
a fantastic maintainer of the
Objective-C library, Greg
Robbins, who's been really
good about adding
new things to it.
So it's not like you're in very
bad shape if you wanted
to use the Objective-C client
library with v2.
That being said, it'll
strictly be a better
experience I think I could say
with some degree of certainty
if you're doing v3 programming
using the
Objective-C client library.
And you know, it's definitely
something
that should be supported.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And eight other languages,
right?
JEFFREY POSNICK: And eight
other languages, yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sounds good.
Couple of final questions
since we
have a few more minutes.
So there was one question about
embedding videos on one
side from a YouTube channel.
So if someone has a bunch of
videos uploaded, how can they
easily embed them
on the channel?
And then can they actually
decide how
the videos are presented?
There was a specific question
about determining the order by
sorting based on tag values or
maybe any part of metadata.
Any hints of how that
can be done?
What are the possibilities
there?
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
So I want to make sure I fully
understand the question.
I'm not sure you're the person
to clarify it or not.
So let me answer the assumption
that the person has
a list of videos, either already
in a playlist or
already in their account or
maybe just a list of arbitrary
video IDs, and their goal
is to display them in an
intelligent fashion on a web
page in some sort of player.
Does that kind of sound
like what--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure.
That's the general case.
I think the uploads case was
another one, the simple case.
So maybe we could cover both.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure.
So what you would want to do in
that particular case is use
our standard embedded player
but make use of its list
playback capabilities.
So we talked about that a little
bit in a blog post.
And here, since I'm in the
screen-sharing mode, let me
just pull up that particular
post and try and make it a
little bit bigger.
Just so folks know what I'm
talking about here.
So if you go to our
blog, which is at
apiblog.youtube.com, you can
just search for list, just
like I just did, and you'll
find this blog post.
And we talk about how you
could use our standard
icon-embedded player, but use
some parameters over here that
let you say, OK, I would like
the player to be populated
with all the uploads within
this user name, Google
Developer, in this case.
The other types of values that
you can do is say, I would
like this to be populated
with all the
videos in a given playlist.
So you say playlist over here
and you put in playlist ID
right over there.
And you'll automatically get
a player that will load up
everything in the playlist and
play those back to your users.
It is actually kind of nice
because you get these little
thumbnails on the bottom when
you zoom in even more, so you
can see these thumbnails
that I'm talking about.
So you can get these thumbnails
of all the
different past videos so users
could just jump to the
specific one that they
want to go to.
Let me start with Google Git
engine in this case.
So that's kind of our
recommended way of doing it
without having to write too
much code of your own.
If you did want to write more
code, feel free to do so.
And you can use our Data API,
for instance, to get the
contents of a given playlist or
the contents of user upload
speed, and then take all those
video IDs and represent them
in any fashion that makes
sense to you.
That's kind of really
up to the developer.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Thanks, Jeff.
There was one question asked by
someone on the live stream.
Where can they find more
information about the API?
Jeremy, since I know you've been
right in the middle of
trying to figure out all the
intricacies of the API, where
would one start?
From your experience, what's
a good starting point?
JEREMY WALKER: Well, if you look
on the site where you'd
normally get the Version 2,
there's actually a Version 3
link right above it that
says experimental.
And you can go into that.
There's some good examples in
there that I, in fact, started
playing around with.
And also great documentation
that breaks down all the parts
that Jeff went over and how to
get different parts of that
back in your responses.
So if you just go to the main
YouTube API page, you'll see
it under the Data API section
as Version 3, Experimental.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Thanks, Jeremy.
I know you've been studying
it very carefully.
All right.
So we're almost out of time.
There's one final note that
I wanted to make.
If you guys would like to help
us with developer activities,
we are hiring.
If you go to
developers.google.com/jobs,
you will see some of
the positions that
we have on our team.
It is a lot of fun, and as you
can tell, there's a lot of new
APIs coming out.
We work with a lot of
developers, entrepreneurs,
large, small companies.
We engage in the community
online, live Hangouts.
So a lot of different types of
things that you might find
interesting.
So if you would like to check
it out, please do so.
And I think this wraps it up for
today's episode of Google
Developers Live and YouTube
Developers Live.
Thank you very much
for your time.
And we'll see you next week.
10 o'clock AM, Wednesday,
Pacific.
JEREMY WALKER: Thanks.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Bye, everybody.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]